blog mans giorno 6
non ho abbastanza mani quando mi sono
svegliato deciso di fare una sorpresa a
enrico perché ho voglia di fare un bel
regalo al mio fratello stiamo lavorando
insieme ovviamente alcuni di video che
vedete in realtà limonta lui ormai sono
diventati un team
praticamente è al momento li sta
montando con la mio computer che mi
manca tantissimo io ogni volta sto con
il fisso e non so come fare quindi ho
pensato sia per tornaconto personale ma
che per fargli capire che apprezzo molto
il suo lavori fargli un piccolo regalo a
partire dalla videocamera ripresa
inutile dai neo muovere mineo muore e
non capirai fosse per me regalerei il
mondo ha una famiglia
cosa che non è assolutamente vera l'ho
detta solamente per sembrare buono come
realtà sono crudele non gli regalerei
oggi eri cosi bacon macbook
gli altri due però si faranno non lo so
tutte le cose che tutti i macbook che
poi non ho più usato gli dati allora
ricupo venere l'unico senza quindi se lo
merita
soltanto il dente e 80 81 38
[Musica]
sono tornato in macchina o il regalo di
mio fratello
avevo preso pure la carta da regalo la
coccarda e un bigliettino
il problema è che quando sto per andare
a pagare il proprietario di questa
cartoleria che sta ad entrare nel
portale di roma ha trattato mare una sua
dipendente
ci ha dato una risposta un po così molto
sgarbata tra parentesi è una ragazza
supergentile altra trappolone ho pensato
che non li meritasse i miei soldi un
posto nel quale il proprietario sfrutta
il suo potere per poter trattare magari
gente alla fine sono andato in questo al
negozietto aperto non solo vedete se ti
ho scritto con con questa signora
orientale gentilissima gentilissima
gentilissima che davano tutto quello che
cercavo la cosa interessante che avevo
420 ho speso 420 quindi abbiamo scritto
nelle stelle che andassi da lei non da
quel maleducato che tratta male sui
dipendenti
allora scusate un piazzato il coso lì
nella speranza che pena la mia faccia
eccola 20 mia foto non potevo fare
meglio insieme ma no beh questo addio ma
niente allora presto computer sono
contento che di fatto sul regalo anche
se domani andro a vivere sotto i ponti
troppo contento giostra merita perché
purtroppo pazzesco non solo meri fatti
sentire le forbici schifo
ecco un taglio di carta senza pollici
per adesso che mi dia que me dentro
dovrebbero esserci luigi ma quando dai
adesso sta incartando in macchina bel
regalo di natale
beh è il regalo di natale del matrimonio
di pasqua perché sto girando il video di
micro sta incartando quindi enrico lo
vedrai vedrai montaggio questa cosa e
non voglio che lo scontro è comunque ho
pagato 1.300 euro copre solamente la mia
casa non è a generosità a quel bar ma
scusa tu non senti mai che gli scotch a
volte sanno di fungo ma ero che la colla
è la cosa che ti ritrovo capivo dure è
vero che se tipo scocciarsi una
salsiccia capito così in termini ma
restano scajola se un po strappata la
carta la bestia cantoni l'opera
stracciando la quindi non figurativo del
titano ma che aspetterà spero non si
aspetta da me pare che se lo aspetta se
sono aspetti del mito viziato
ho preso un c'è un bigliettino ed è un
bigliettino di un battesimo
ok è assolutamente rosa e assumono
interessa che richiamo un pochino questo
questo oro pallido un post molto però
sai come io so pure daltonico
la penna che gli scrivo non purtroppo
non c'è una penna ma non si parla al
volo perché non più soldi e spreca tutto
quanto me prendere è costata investite
in qualche posto e non aveva alcuno è
però magari una vena calabretta al culo
che confina me la vado vado in missione
ma di missione non sto portando tipo in
maniera casual capire cioè che tipo
potrebbe anche sbatte contro i muri a me
non interessa per niente perché non è
una cosa di valore assicura enrico
errico non c'è in compenso c'è lui chi
cerca attenzioni circa attenzioni lui
aspetta molto molto mi dispiace devo
prima andare a fare una missione segreta
di prego manine fini fa che hanno ha
dato la perla quello che vuoi
un regalo per te chiedo scusa per
l'abbigliamento di mio fratello enrico
ma quando sta a casa tranquillo senza
videocamera accesa sembra che sia uscito
la corte dei miracoli ogni volta
sono curioso anch'io sono curioso perché
questo a quanto pare invece sapete cos'è
la più pallida idea di cosa c'è scritto
un capitolo è un piccolo pensiero per
una grande persona palude il tuo peso
magari tutta l'asta alta gara in tarda
di stracciare non ci credo non ci credo
più aride commenti a caldo o freddo con
la videocamera nascosta fra in questi
chili per cosi in una maniera becera
unboxing mentre i fan boxing si no io
sono un mese tu solo in inglese netto
dice qualcosa in inglese
certo sto cercando di fare un salto alle
poste trovarle aperte per andare a
prendere delle multe ma forse non
ricevute altri perché non mandano le
mail per chi è riuscito con rotto ed è
un ottimo sappiamo quante multe cose
così
questo dei secoli non vado alle poste di
roba qua dentro
l'affare conteranno molto da solo
scusate io vorrei fare un appello allo
stato
ormai nel 2000 e quasi diciannove le
persone difficilmente hanno nei loro
palazzi un portiere e difficilmente il
2019 stanno a casa tutto il tempo la
mattina o il pomeriggio perché più delle
volte magari lavorano senza contare che
invece dopo neppure rotto quindi se un
possibile né a citofonare mi sento il
mio cita fra il rotore nonno perché
ancora non l'ho fatto sostituire perché
non mandiamo delle mail perché non
abbiamo ancora sbloccato la multa
tramite e mail
chi è questo babbo natale ok ora che lo
per te
secondo me ma il totale delle multe
permettono nato a casa
babbo postale mi ha portato due multe e
adesso le scartiamo insieme
ok chiesto i calzini caso dio allora
prima di recente io sono andato a
ritirarla però io ho ritirato le poste
una cosa che mi dice di ritirare alle
poste la multa effetto questa invece
bella verde e piacere ok se vuol dire mi
dicono che non ho fatto vedere dove
conosciamo il mio veicolo cioè c'è tv un
momento di sdoppiate ciao ragazze ho più
ricevuto una multa per aver fatto una
cosa che non ho mai fatto ossia di far
vedere i miei documenti a qualcuno che
mi ha bloccato tipo all'e3 interessano
vede notte
poiché senza giustificato e documentato
motivo non ottemperava all'invito di
fornire informazioni sui dati personali
sulla patente di guida di colui che in
data 19 12 2007 alle ore 3 39 conduceva
il veicolo mini per violazione dell'art
che sia questa assurda non sto capendo
anche perché vuol dire che uno è stato
fermato per l'invasione si sono
sbagliati colorata non ci voleva pagarlo
estero scherzi a parte se qualcuno ha
capito qualcosa mi può scrivere qua
sotto che cosa vuol dire questa molto e
che cosa dovrei fare qualora io non
avessi mai commesso un reato di questo
tipo per dire fatto abbiamo messo tra le
note aggiunta pena mamme su tutti i
tracciati sul bur rita aggiunta di
cipolla fritta ricordarci cosa mie sogni
a volontà il prima possibile si trovano
sotto chiamare al telefono grazie
qualche altra cosa gioco come state
scusate questo giorno che non finisce
più sta arrivando
lui in stazione sono contento perché
passiamo lui che insieme faremo un sacco
di cose finalmente natalizie perché oggi
il natalizio c'è stato veramente poco
oddio non fatto un regalo ecco lui
ecco qui è venuto a roma non ce la fai
vincere non siamo così vecchiaia ha
sempre sfocato questa mattina opzioni
in tutto questo c'è luigi che si sta
mangiando i corn flakes
tra l'altro gli avanzi dico ma sei un
coniglio ma perché ma che è ma che è ma
che è ma che è ma che è ma che visto che
abbiamo deciso di proseguire la dieta
che sono in cui con delle persone che
non ho mai visto la mucca segale ti
piace un regalo di 10
si no
[Risate]
avevo passato dietro la testa riprendeva
la secca possibile ragazzi invece
vediamo naturalmente domani come
un'altra puntata impropri massa alle 14
14 che risata barba